If I get a stomachache after eating even good foods, is that a sign that I have allergies to that food?
No, I would say no, so if
If you got a stomachache, so usually a food allergy, so let's say you have antibodies to a food
Let's use gluten as an example. Let's say I have antibodies to gluten
Well, I always get a stomachache after eating gluten. No, you won't. It could take up to 16-18 hours for you to feel any ill-effects
even in your gut from eating a food that you have antibodies against. So I don't think, you know, if I got a stomachache to eating food, I'll say,
well, if I eat that, it just bothers me. Could that be a sign of allergies?
Yeah, I mean, you could, it could possibly be, but more likely, it could be to hypochloridria. So if I get a stomachache after eating good food,
could it be allergies? Yeah, it could be. That is a possibility. Anything is possible. But what's the most likely thing?
It could be hypochloridria. That's probably the most common thing. So if I don't have enough hydrochloric acid in my stomach and I eat food,
it's not going to be properly digested. It's going to go into my smell and tested improperly digested
and larger bolus and it's going to cause issues with digestion, issues with absorption, probably increase in
the, it's going to be a larger size and it's going to cause inflammation. And that's where you're going to have more stomach pain or gut pain.
Because most of your pain fibers in your intestinal tract are what are called distention fibers. So if the intestines are, you know,
are distended in size, that's what's going to cause that's what's going to cause pain. That's what's going to be the pain. That's why they have a lot of gas.
The gas is going to extend the intestinal tract that you're going to have pain from gas.
So I would be more thinking of that making sure that you're, that you're taking a digestive enzyme with HCl with your food.
There's different foods that are going to be harder for you to digest. I mean any kind of protein, you're going to need more HCl.
That's why I typically recommend people to judge the amount of digestive enzymes and HCl based upon what they're eating, the size of their meal is a piece of that as well.
Certainly if you're like, no, I got all that covered. I think it's always when I eat this particular food, then for sure that you could think of that could be some type of sensitivity.
Either doing a food elimination process or doing a Cyrex antibody test would be in order to see what's going on.